thank you I'm delighted to be back at
Yale with many old friends my thanks to
the director of Francis Rosenberg for
the invitation to Kelly Ann Farnham
Charlotte Holman Joelle Besh for
excellent logistical support and all of
you for coming as you can hear I have a
bit of a cold but if you are traveling
having trouble let me know and I'll rip
my throat out so the title of these
overall titled these lectures is that is
not who we are
populism and stories of people hood the
title of this lecture is a cacophony of
stories and in the fall of 2018 around
the globe nothing is more striking than
the increasing prominence and power of
movements and leaders and political
stories labelled populist journalists
and scholars alike most often apply the
term to anti-immigrant authoritarian
leaning leaders and parties like Victor
Orbin and Fidesz and hungry Sebastien
Kurtz and the Austrian People's Party
geert wilders in the party for freedom
in the netherlands marine lepen and the
National Front in France the law and
justice party in Poland the Danish
People's Party the alternative for
Deutschland in Germany the coalition
government of the five star movement and
the anti-immigrant League in Italy and
many more populist often is also used to
describe national authoritarian leaders
like Rodrigo Duterte in the Philippines
and sometimes Vladimir Putin in Russia
and Xi Jinping in China it's also
applied to figures emphasizing religious
conceptions of national identity like
reshef type air Dhawan and the Justice
and Development Party in Turkey and
Narendra Modi and the BJP in India but
the populist label is appended as well
to more secular economically
left-leaning actors like Hugo Chavez and
his
troubled successor nicolas maduro in
venezuela alexis tsipras and Tsaritsa in
greece and toxin and Yingluck Shinawatra
in thailand as well as Bernie Sanders in
the u.s. among others populist is a
title coveted by many proponents of
breakfast such as Boris Johnson and it's
not only applied to its eagerly embraced
by the current American president Donald
J Trump not all of these populist
leaders and movements are now in power
but in many places they are and they are
shaping political developments
everywhere in light of the variety of
leaders in movements now being called
populist analysts have been devoting a
great deal of attention to two questions
first what the term populism really
means and second what the causes of
contemporary populism are with the
answers to the second question partly
dependent on the first scholars have
paid somewhat less attention to the
topic that's my focus in these lectures
the question of what types of responses
to pathological forms of populism are
feasible and desirable I will make a
case for what the elements desirable
accounts have shared political
identities of good stories of people
hood are because I contend these stories
along with other measures are needed to
combat the worst forms of populism today
to make that case it will help first to
review briefly the current scholarship
on what we should call populism and what
its causes may be in recent pop public
discourse on the what is populism
question perhaps the most influential
view is John Verner Mueller's in his
appropriately entitled book what is
populism muler has argued that populism
is a moralized form of anti pluralism an
inherently illiberal form of identity
politics that is given to internal
authoritarianism and allegiance to a
leader believed to embody popular will
moolah rejects calling such populism
pathological because he believes the
ethology label implies that supporters
of populist leaders are irrational with
few reasonable grievances or goals he
acknowledges however that his definition
is most descriptive of the contemporary
populist movements in his native Europe
and does not work well for the late 19th
century American people's parties and
attendant movements that were the prime
American examples of populism at least
prior to Trump these movements were
internally Democratic often they
embraced racial and ethnic minorities
and women as equals sometimes only
rhetorically but sometimes as leaders
they also did not follow an
authoritarian figure so I'm inclined to
say again smaller that the American
people's party and many other
self-proclaimed populist movements that
are broadly democratic deserve to be
called by the term but they wish to be
called so I do refer to strongly anti
pluralists illiberal and authoritarian
populist movements as pathological forms
of populism not because I see their
adherence as irrational but because they
are the variants of populism that are
most likely to produce the ill effects
with which more I and many others are
concerned they are the ones most likely
to exclude repress and persecute ethnic
and religious others and to pursue the
forms of constitutional self-governance
while in actuality imposing
dictatorships for similar reasons many
scholars writing on populism adopt more
expansive definitions than Muller
perhaps the most influential in academic
circles is caste muda often writing with
Cristobal Culp Wasser they've long
argued for what they term a minimal
definition of populism as a thin
centered ideology that considers society
to be ultimately separated into two
homogeneous and I'm taken antagonistic
camps the pure people versus the corrupt
elite and which argues that politics
should be an expression of the general
will of the people for these authors
populist movements can be internally
democratic without subservience to a
leader claiming to embody that general
will though
often such populist leaders arise yet
others argue that even this definition
goes too far they contend that the
people in populist movements need not be
conceived as homogeneous pure or as
possessing a Russo Ian's general will
many scholars building on a nurse Tolec
Lao maintained that all that is required
for a viewer movement to be populous is
an insistence first that politics is
fundamentally about the clashes between
the people and the elite however defined
and second that only the people can
confer legitimacy on political and
governmental actions similarly many
contributors to the recent oxford
handbook of populism see populism simply
as a quote thin centered ideology that
posits a struggle between the will of
the common people and a conspiring elite
this even more minimal definition allows
us to deem populist both movements with
left-leaning economic agendas as in
parts of Latin America and Greece today
and right-leaning
as well as more centrist ones it also
enables us to include internally
democratic parties and movements that
have embraced a significant degree of
pluralism and have not followed an
authoritarian leader like the 19th
century American People's Party because
I prefer definitions that map on to
actual usages in the world I will use
the Oxford Handbook still more
minimalist expansive and inclusive
definition of populism here with one
important addition that I will specify
shortly but admittedly using this broad
definition makes responding to the
second question the causes of the
contemporary surge in various movements
all labeled populist even more
challenging the diverse streams of
populism flowing in the world today are
not likely all to be traceable to the
same spring however analysts of modern
populism actually are fairly United on
the factors they discuss though they
disagree sometimes sharply on those
factors relative weight some emphasize
economic concerns including insecurities
prompted by heightening inequalities and
men
dimensions of economic globalization as
well as technological innovations these
economic anxieties are often reinforced
by perceptions that mainstream political
parties and leaders are at best
dismissive of poor people's economic
worries and at worse they're corrupt
tools of wealthy elites other analysts
however stress cultural factors senses
of loss of status and secure identity in
the face of demographic and cultural
shifts wrought by heightened immigration
secularization minority liberation
movements and other trends these
scholars see populist adherents as
enraged at cosmopolitan cultural elites
perceived to be contemptuous of more
traditionalist beliefs and ways of life
at the extreme moreover many populist
are seen as driven not just by cultural
traditionalism but variant religious
bigotry and racism in the recent essay
on the causes of populism Kirk Hawkins
Madeleine read and tuned pavel see force
in both these strands of explanation
they also call however for greater
attention to the content of populist
ideas the reasons people have for
deciding two conspiring elites whether
economic or cultural or both are ruining
their lives these scholars see populism
as rooted in belief in democracy faith
and democracy accompanied by the
conviction that things are bad it must
be that the leaders are failing to
people so that individuals become
receptive to rhetorical frames that
assign blame to elites like all these
authors I see great power in both the
economic and cultural strands of
explanation for the causes of
contemporary populism I will not focus
on those causes here but that is because
I seek not to challenge prevailing
accounts only to add to them in doing so
I will build on the argument that we
should attend at the content of populist
ideas and that most populist supporters
genuinely embrace conceptions of
democracy notions that the people
rightly defined are the source of
political legitimacy however I wish to
take this concern with the content of
populist ideas in a
front direction the most analysts are
doing Hawkins Reid and pebbles for
example end up calling for more
attention to the policy attitudes of
popular voters in the manner of
mainstream public opinion scholars they
do not examine whom different populist
movements say are the people whose will
and interest should govern and why the
people deserve to govern they do not
give much concrete attention in short to
populist versions of what I call stories
of people who yet even though
globalizing forces creating job
displacements economic inequalities
greater demographic diversity heightened
urbanization and often senses of
disempowerment all provide conditions
conducive to populist revolts against
new economic and cultural elites those
revolts are neither inevitable nor
wholly self-actualizing there are always
elements of contingent political agency
at work leaders must advance populist
stories of people who've that persuade
people to interpret their experiences in
certain ways they can do so in any
number of ways for better and worse
consequently failure to attend to the
populist stories that political leaders
are advancing on who the people are how
they are aggrieved and what they should
do can lead scholars to overlook both a
significant contributing cause and a
possible cure for pathological populism
today that's why I want to add one
element to the Oxford Handbook of
populism minimalist definition of
populism I wish to insist that every
populist ideology has some story
explaining who the people are and why
they are more deserving than elites and
that we must engage with these stories
if we hope to render populist movements
more genuinely democratic and respectful
of the rights and dignity of all so
let's consider stories for a few minutes
in his international bestseller sapiens
the Israeli historian you've all her re
argues that all large-scale forms of
human cooperation whether quote a modern
Statham
evil Church in ancient city or an art or
an archaic tribe are rooted in people's
collective imagination in the stories
that people tell one another
Harare believes that the unique feature
of our species Homo sapiens and the real
source of our species ability to rule
the world is our ability to cooperate
flexibly in large numbers he thinks that
capacity for large-scale cooperation
rests in turn on our abilities to
compose and to embrace myths or stories
of our common identities interests and
purposes
it is shared belief in these stories
that persuades us both that we can trust
one another
and that it would be worthwhile to help
one another in his words now I'm not so
bold to proclaim like Harare that our
storytelling and story believing
abilities are what sets us Homo sapiens
apart from and above all other species
on earth including Neanderthals and
mastodons still I've long analyzed the
politics of Homo sapiens very similarly
I've continued that political
communities are always created and
sustained by combinations of coercive
force and persuasive stories because in
there are ease words one cannot organize
an army solely by coercion there must be
some true believers among them if they
are to be relied upon in conflicts my
focus has been on the stories of what I
call political people's which I define
as any and all human associations groups
and communities that are commonly
understood to assert that their members
oh them a measure of allegiance against
the demands of other associations
communities and groups the more
demanding the claims the more political
of the group this definition means that
there's a wide range of weaker and
stronger forms of political peoplehood I
have also argued like Harare that
stories of people hood work to inspire
necessary senses of trust among fellow
members of a community and between the
members and their leaders as well as
senses of the worth of their community
membership I further contended that
any story of political people hood to
sustain senses of collective identity
and cooperative endeavors over time must
persuasively advance three basic themes
though it can do so with different
emphases and different degrees of a
success it must have an economic theme
promising both personal and collective
material well-being it must have a
political power theme promising both
personal safety and community power
sufficient for collective self-defense
as well as perhaps a significant measure
of political voice we must also have
what I have termed a constitutive theme
one presenting membership in a
particular community as intrinsic to who
the members really are because of traits
deemed to be normatively good one of my
core claims is that even though no
political society is likely to endure if
it does not have credible economic and
political power themes with confirming
results for a critical mass of its
members it's also true that no political
society can long sustain itself through
economic and political power benefits
alone it's not just economics and
politics there's the ethics part in EPE
there will inevitably be economic and
political down times that's why they're
not enough so political communities must
also be maintained by senses of
Allegiance rooted in beliefs that being
part of that community is part of its
members core identities and a part that
gives their lives meaning and worth
constitutive themes may feature religion
ancestry ethnicity race gender rules
language culture class customs and more
but they always present the traits they
feature as marks of high value and as
integral to who we are my previous
discussions of stories of people hood
have focused on these constitutive
themes because they're not so commonly
discussed much less stressed in
contemporary political science which
instead emphasizes economic and
political power interests i've also
focused on nationalist stories of people
who are stories of nationhood because
they remain the most prevalent in most
demanding the most likely to claim
supreme authority with some real
efficacy in today's world but here I'll
go further a central claim I wish to
make is that a contributing factor to
the rise of modern populism
particularly nationalistic populism has
been a decline in genuinely hegemonic
stories of people hood combined with a
proliferation of thematically very
diverse and often conflicting stories of
people hood some of these stories
highlight economic benefits some
political power concerns other a.y
others a wide variety of constitutive
themes some are nationalistic but many
are anti nationalists championing a
great diversity of other possible
memberships and allegiances collectively
they have generated a cacophony of
stories of identities and obligations
that many find painful today this
cacophony has made clear simple familiar
nationalistic stories and slogans sound
like siren songs to millions until
recently many analysts stressed to the
contrary that a variety of forms of
globalization were producing greater
economic ideological and cultural
homogeneity making the world flat in
Thomas Friedman's famous phrase however
today many perceive a complex dialectic
of globalization and fragmentation that
is contributing to a massive
proliferation of stories of political
peoplehood that I see is in many ways
exciting and promising but that many see
and rightly see as deeply unsettling
this dialectic arises many scholars
suggest because globalization has
fostered transnational economic
communication social and political
networks and associations but also and
simultaneously new potential for many
sub communities to flourish without
extensive reliance on a national state
that potential is all the more
significant as contemporary projects of
State Building and state maintaining are
often faltering leading to estimates
that up to 80 percent of the world's
population resides in limited
or failed states so today's increasingly
globalized yet increasingly fragmented
world Foster's countless rapidly
proliferating rival stories of political
peoplehood that challenge the dominance
of narratives of national identity but
these conditions also provide motives
and opportunities for proponents of
nationalistic narratives to push back to
be sure for as far back as we know human
beings have had what we would now term
multiple identities as bearers of
certain genders as family members as
adherents of religious communities as
practitioners of occupations and as
participants in political societies of
various sorts amongst other rules and
statuses but it's plausible to believe
that through most of human history few
people felt routinely confronted by so
many diverse and conflicting stories of
what their core political peoplehood
should be as most persons are now it is
true that the capacities of Homo sapiens
to create communicate stories have
enabled us for millennia to form notions
of peoples and ways of life different
from our own but things have changed in
recent decades modern communication
systems greater mobility and urbanizing
trends have significantly transformed
most people's lives shifting more and
more of the world's population into a
groups into extraordinarily diverse and
extensively wired global cities making
exposure to multiple stories almost
inescapable in contrast most people
throughout most of human history lived
most of their lives in relative
isolation up to the end of World War two
more than two-thirds of the world's
population lived in rural areas with
limited access to vast communication
systems all through their lives they
mostly heard long familiar stories of
who they were and might be told by local
familial religious and political leaders
even the higher political figures and
broader communities that may have
claimed authority over them seemed
remote stories depicting identities and
ways of life substantially different
from those they were person
seem pursuing seem more like
entertaining fantasies than concrete
options that groups were urging them to
pursue the stories they heard moreover
generally presented their multiple
identities their familial statuses
gender roles occupations religious
memberships and political allegiances as
all mutually compatible interwoven and
integrated into a relatively coherent
sense of who they were and what they
should be a sense that most of those
around them shared and reinforced few
experienced frequent demands to
reconsider or choose among their
possible political identities and
obligations I don't mean that life was
generally pastoral and peaceful
conflicts and power struggles at all
levels have been endemic throughout
human history
however conflicts can occur and probably
most routinely did occur through people
seeking to heighten the importance of
their rules or to gain a higher station
among the conventional rules and
statuses defined with the prevailing
narratives of their communities army
commanders wanted to be emperors barons
wanted to be kings
the battles did not so often arise from
clashes of narratives depicting what
their political communities and who
their core identities should be of
course political societies often did
compete with other societies with the
disputes frequently settled by force
conquerors often imposed on the
conquered a new sense of their political
identities expressed in the victors
stories of political people hood still
up until roughly the last 400 years most
human beings lived in villages small
cities or nomadic tribes that managed
through winning occasional battles or
through the collapse of any overarching
Authority to maintain or regain their
autonomy or else they were part of
empires mostly they were part of empires
up through World War two in the ensuing
era of decolonization the bulk of the
world's population was chiefly governed
by Imperial regimes of one sort or
another from the Assyrian Empire to the
Persian to the sequence of Chinese
empires as well as the Roman the
Byzantine the Arab Caliphate the Ottoman
the Mughal the Incan the Aztec empires
the Spanish French
British Empire's and many more yet the
Imperial gully governed were often
loosely governed
although these empires varied enormously
in many respects most had multi-level
overlapping jurisdictions and apart from
collecting taxes and compelling military
service most shared power with the local
leaders they favored in the communities
they conquered they permitted
considerable local self-governance that
left a wide array of religions
occupations ethnic identities and
cultural ways of life and so a great
variety of traditional identities
relatively unchallenged consequently
though they propagated stories of
Imperial peoplehood that shaped the
identities of those they ruled over time
in significant ways for many Imperial
subjects this new political identity was
a relatively unobtrusive layer added on
to the familiar ones that continued to
characterize who they were and what they
did on most days of their lives even
those who chose to resist their imperial
conquerors generally did so out of a
firm sense of their preceding
traditional identities and obligations
that enabled them to see their political
world as a straightforward
us-versus-them
then came the global decolonization
movements that followed World War two
the long period when empires were the
most prevalent form of political regime
around the globe gave way to a new era
that we often treat as older than it
really is this is the era in which
national states at last became the
overwhelmingly predominant kind of
political society around the globe
culminating a process that began in
Europe in at the earliest the sixteenth
century
and gained ideological impetus across
the globe with the late 18th century
American and French Revolutions though
exact numbers can vary with different
definitions the world possessed roughly
50 sovereign states in 1945 as World War
two ended by 1989 as the end of the
European and Japanese empires in Africa
and Asia especially generated a host of
new national states the number of states
had more than tripled to over 180 for
the first time
these sorts of states govern most of the
world's population yet this
multiplication of states did not foster
experiences of fragmented and competing
political identities to the degree that
many are experiencing today for one
major reason this brave new world of
national states displayed an overarching
indeed hegemonic structure driven by the
rivalry between the capitalist United
States and its global allies and the
Communist Soviet Soviet Union and its
allies many states to be sure were
unaligned and most states displayed some
level of ongoing internal contestation
over whether they should align in a
different way than they were currently
doing especially those wrestling with
the legacies of imperialism which
included many continuing forms of
Imperial influence even so during the
Cold War the stories of political people
hood that competed in most people's
experience gained some simplicity and
clarity from their answer to one great
question on which side of the Iron
Curtain do we stand
the centrality of this divide helps
States on both sides to accept new
transnational agreements and
institutions including NATO on the one
hand and the Warsaw Pact on the other
which they might otherwise have seen as
reducing their national sovereignty it
also prompted support in much of the
West for new pro-capitalist global
economic institutions including the
International Monetary Fund the World
Bank and eventually the World Trade
Organization even as communist nations
like Cuba and North Korea relied on aid
from the Soviet Union and the People's
Republic of China I grew up in this
world and I can attest that at a psychic
level it made choices about political
identity not just for States but for
individuals seem more straightforward
than they do today the threat of nuclear
war was always in the background and
often in the forefront of our minds
swallowing up all other differences in
concerns and thereby promoting
relatively integrated senses of who we
were when in 1961 John F Kennedy
structured his inaugural address around
the opposition between in his words to
Great and Powerful groups of Nations
both racing to alter that uncertain
balance of terror that stays the hand of
mankind's final war he told a compelling
story of global politics in which we all
knew our place then in 1989 the Cold War
ended the Soviet Union fell launching
another wave a post-imperial state
building so that today the UN has 195
member states like many other parts of
past empires the former Soviet satellite
nations have often struggled to
construct coherent much less compelling
stories of people who to replace the
ones that prevailed when the lives of
those involved were shaped by standing
for or against an imperial regime or for
or against the communist or capitalist
bloc compounding these difficulties
these struggles have occurred in a
context in which the dialectics of
globalization and fragmentation means
that most states are confronting rising
numbers of persuasive alternative
accounts of their would-be constituents
possible political memberships and
obligations let me offer some examples
up through 1989 one could Kuehl your
feature of many of the states that
foregrounded communism in their stories
of people hood such as Yugoslavia
Czechoslovakia and the Soviet Union
itself is that they also structured
themselves as ethno federal states with
subdivisions and even personal identity
cards that drew upon and reinforced
pre-existing ethno-cultural communities
they did so in part to elicit support
for their political regimes beyond those
that the economic and political power
themes provided by communist ideologies
could summon when communism fell these
states faced choices about whether they
should remain unitary states and about
what sorts of national identities they
should embrace they responded in
different ways in 1990 the former
Czechoslovakia lists Republic first
became the Czech and Slovak Federative
Republic and then in 1992 broke into two
new states the Czech and Slovak
Republic's the latter commonly called
Slovakia
as Nadia Adel ski has shown the Czech
Republic like most of the former Soviet
bloc states in the 1990s adopted what
has frequently turned a civic conception
of their identity stressing that their
state was a Federation of free and equal
citizens dedicated to human rights and
democracy Slovakia instead chose what is
often termed an ethnic conception of its
identity its constitution identified
itself as the product of the Slovak
nation exercising the natural right of
Nations to self-determination in order
to advance the political and cultural
heritage of our forefathers while also
allowing a place for minority
nationalities living on its territories
both Republic's however included some
who retained a sense of their identities
primarily as communist others remain
loyal to the formerly United
Czechoslovakia still others were
actually more strongly attached to the
kind of political identity proclaimed in
the Republic in which they did not
reside then the one in which they did
many more were simply left uncertain
about who or what their political
identities should be in each of the New
Republic's moreover national minorities
expressed concerns that their new states
would not adequately protect them
against discrimination or recognize
their distinctive identities as a result
the members of both these new states
faced a multiplicity of competing
stories of their political peoplehood
that we're no longer subordinated under
their membership in the Soviet bloc the
same has been true of many other
formerly communist nations some of which
have swung between more civic and more
ethnic national self conceptions like
Hungary and Poland and some of which
have faced internal separatist movements
including Russia itself many of the new
nations created by the decolonization
movements earlier in the 20th century
continue to face similar challenges in
in part because so many have boundaries
drawn by their imperial governor's not
chosen by their indigenous residents to
take one striking example although the
Arab Sheik Tom's that now form part of
the United Arab Emirates were never
formally part of the British Empire
Great Britain long used treaties with
their
her cheeks to exercise extensive control
over the region especially after the
discovery of oil in Bahrain in 1932 but
in 1968 the British chose to withdraw
from the Persian Gulf instituting
discussions amongst the British
protected Gulf states that led in 1971
to the founding of the United Arab
Emirates as Calvert Jones a Yale PhD has
detailed this new political regime has
since its inception faced major
difficulties in fostering a sense of
common national identity among its
members there simply was no historical
shared Emirati identity upon which to
build not even a sense of common cause
born of shared anti-colonial struggles
most UAE residents had instead grown up
with strong distinct and often
conflicting tribal identities
however the Emirates did have oil money
as well as inherited tribal customs in
which rulers provided goods to their
tribesmen so it's not surprising that
early on the UAE government sought to
foster loyalty chiefly through an
economic story of people hood they told
those they governed in effect if you
embrace membership in the UAE you will
be eligible for state provided benefits
in the form of land water houses
clothing shoes foods hospitals vehicles
and more it will immediately be clear
however that purchasing national loyalty
primarily through the provision of
material goods is a problematic strategy
it's likely to produce innumerable
claimants for membership requiring sharp
constraints on access to citizenship if
citizens are indeed to receive extensive
benefits it can also foster a rentier
mentality an ethos of self-indulgence
often lazy dependency by the 1990s
according to Jones UAE rulers had become
vividly conscious of just these problems
they also knew that reliance on oil
could not last forever and that they
would need new strategies to maintain
economic success in a world increasingly
dominated by global market and financial
systems they concluded concluded they
needed to craft a new kind of citizen
one capable of thriving and enabling the
UAE to thrive in the global
economy but the Emirates governing
sheiks faced major challenges in doing
so they still had difficulty advancing
any compelling ethno-cultural account of
UAE identity their state remains
historically recent and though many of
their citizens valued older tribal pan
Arabic or Muslim identities too much
emphasis on those allegiances could cut
against national loyalties many
proponents of those identities
especially Islamists and frequently
criticized the government's economic
vision of Emirati peoplehood as a
corrupt Western imposition even as
others attacked the Islamists for
favouring foreign versions of Islam over
emirati traditions so the ruling sheets
were understandably wary of the lying
too greatly with movements trumpeting
those ethnic cultural themes moreover
because the UAE does limit access to
citizenship in its material benefits
even as it also relies extensively on
immigrant labour UAE citizens are a
small privileged minority within the far
larger and more diverse resident alien
population of their own country UAE
elites consequently complained that it
is difficult to foster a sense of
Emirati cultural identity when for
example so many children are raised by
Filipino nannies nor can the regime
easily rely on winning loyalty through
political power stories since their
strength lies in wealth not military
force and the Emirates monarchs do not
wish to give most of their citizens much
less the other residents they rule any
real voice in government as a result the
UAE s rulers had little choice but to
try to tweak their economic themes
explaining why citizens should value
belonging to the United Arab Emirates
they've sought to persuade their members
that their citizenship is indeed a road
to wealth but wealth that should be came
be gained by becoming loyal bourgeois
citizens who display a vigorous
entrepreneurial spirit with lots of
self-reliance and initiative and a
strong work ethic to quote the
government's 2010 strategic plan UAV
vision 2021 kalbert Jones finds however
that so far the UAE s pursuit of this
vision has had very mixed success
younger citizens all too often become
what she calls entitled Patriots they
are fully persuaded that they are
exceptional people in an exceptional
country that provides that citizens with
past the prosperity and status but many
still prefer to get wealth through
government jobs rather than their own
business startups those who do pursue
entrepreneurial identities moreover and
particularly those who do so
successfully often come to see
themselves as primarily members of a
transnational cosmopolitan community of
global economic elites rather than
chiefly as dedicated UAE citizens the
inhabitants of many post-colonial
regime's similarly find themselves
confronting movements in groups
advancing a variety of stories of who
they are and where their allegiances
should go to older tribes to States
originally crafted by Imperial rulers to
transnational kaletnik's or fellow
religious believers to global economic
enterprises and endeavors and much more
in such circumstances it's not
surprising that many find it hard to
form a clear sustaining sense of their
political peoplehood the complex
challenges that the interactions of
post-imperial State Building global
economic and social networks and
colonial legacies posed for possessing
secure political identities are also
vividly illustrated by Jan P Dioses new
book a nation on the line which
discusses national narratives in the
Philippines her analysis encompasses
filipino nannies working in places like
the UAE but it focuses on what she calls
the single most important social
cultural and economic development in the
country in the 21st century
aided by state policies the Philippines
have become the call center capital of
the world surpassing India by 2015 the
Filipino call center industry generated
roughly seven point five percent of the
nation's GDP and almost as much as the
remittances of all overseas filipino
workers combined pati OSes research
indicates that this major industry has
been built in part through promotional
narratives stressing that the
philippines historical status as an
american colony has fostered filipino
capacities to speak american-style
English
and deep familiarity with American
cultures these skills enable its workers
to perform call center services for
American customers more effectively than
the call centers of any other nation
industry executives also contend that
Filipinos excel in call center work
because just as their American colonial
governments used to claim they have
innate cultural traits of compassion and
warmth as one business leader put it we
are good at working with the heart
Palio's contends that until recently the
political and economic leaders of the
Philippines wove these imperially shaped
themes of their people's historical and
cultural identities into a proud
national claim that Filipinos are
uniquely equipped to prosper in the
global knowledge economy of the 21st
century they also promised that this new
Philippines IT service economy would
enable overseas Filipino workers like
those nannies in the UAE in the United
Arab Emirates to return home and care
for their own children yet these recent
narratives stress during the cultural
serviceability of Filipinos for
Americans inevitably communicate a
message of linked identity with if not
continuing dependence on the United
States though many fellow Filipinos
relish this story of their peoplehood it
can seem to present them as basically
adjunct Americans and so others find it
alienating it also has turned out there
are limits to how far operating friendly
call centers can take Filipino workers
in the nation as a whole economically so
it's perhaps understandable but more
recently an authoritarian nationalist
populist Rodrigo Duterte has gained
power and often deployed anti-american
rhetoric while exploring a closer
relationship with China though most
recently Duterte seems to have found a
kindred spirit in president Trump in
different ways than the members of this
post-colonial ation are experiencing
shifting and contradictory economic
political and cultural accounts of who
they are and what their aspirations
should be let me stress however that
this experience of struggling with
multiple conflicting stories of people
who it is not at all confined to recent
post-colonial societies in the wake of
the cold war's end and the modern mix of
globe
and fragmentation competing census of
peoplehood have become more visible and
politically significant in most
well-established national regimes as
well
Kathy Kramer's books the politics of
resentment relies on an extensive
observation of informal conversations to
grasp the political perspectives of
rural Wisconsin citizens many of whom
voted first for the populist
anti-establishment Republican Scott
Walker for governor and then for the
still more pronouncedly so Donald Trump
Kramer finds that the rural
consciousness prevalent in Wisconsin
today has three major components that
map well onto my framework for the
typical themes and stories of people
hood she contends that many rural
Wisconsin it--see themselves as part of
a distinctive community that does not
receive its quote fair share of
decision-making power
clearly a political power theme and that
is quote that and that does not receive
quote its fair share of public resources
and economic theme and that is quote
distinct from urban and suburban areas
in their culture and lifestyle a
constitutive identity thing these rural
people believe they do more real hard
work with their hands and backs and that
they are more moral neighborly people
givers not takers in comparisons with
those they see as urban elites who
neither know nor care about their
problems yet they feel they receive far
fewer material rewards than city people
do and they often suffer active disdain
as Hicks and rednecks though there's
story of rural political people who had
blends all three themes I have stressed
recently these Wisconsin citizens have
most pressed their political power
concerns their beliefs that the
governing officials bureaucrats and
associated University experts in the
Capitol in Madison give them no
effective voice in the decisions shaping
their lives partly as a result they
voted for Walker and Trump who both told
them they were right to feel aggrieved
and who promised to be their champions
against the elite objects of their
resentment to be sure the grievances of
rural populations against urbanites are
nothing new in the US or many other
parts of the world it's also certain
that most
Wisconsinites today still see themselves
not just as rural people but as
Wisconsin citizens and US citizens as
well among many other identities still
both the conversations Kramer reports
and their recent voting behavior
suggests that rural Wisconsin ID sense
of themselves as having a distinct and
unjustly treated political identity is
far stronger than it has generally been
in the past they're rural political
people hood is shaping and challenging
there was consonant American people
hoods more than it many other times
they're good reasons for this as Cramer
notes though many rural Wisconsin people
choose to skate groups for their
problems who are not plausibly
responsible for them they do face real
problems it is a reality that in
Wisconsin and in many other places rural
populations are a smaller share of the
population and more distinct along many
Democratic dimensions from the growing
numbers of city dwellers than they've
ever been
at the same time modern communication
systems mean they are less isolated from
those cities in the broader world than
they've ever been so that all the
economic and cultural differences are in
view when they perceive people in power
as for example designing educational
curriculum and student transportation
policies tailored to the social economic
and logistical needs of suburban and
urban populations not to their
distinctive rural needs they are
generally not mistaken those policies
are not designed with them in mind it is
therefore not surprising that rural
Wisconsin Heights are telling themselves
stories and showing they can be
mobilized by stories portraying them as
a distinct virtuous but wrongly
neglected people it is also not
surprising that they cheer for
narratives of Wisconsin and American
citizenship in which they are central
actors and central beneficiaries once
more stories that promise them that they
can be great again the rural urban
divide is moreover just one of
innumerable axis around which distinct
and conflicting senses of political
peoplehood are now forming as an
avalanche of journalism and scholarship
has shown we live in an era of
extraordinarily multifaceted identity
politics the players include
social movements championing racial
identities like black lives matter and
the american indian movement as well as
communities of shared interests an
identity defined by disabilities
sexuality and other traits sometimes
defined as cultural
such as the deaf community and the LGBTQ
community along with a huge variety of
traditional ethnic and immigrant groups
the participants in an identity politics
also include transnational political
advocacy groups for workers for
environmentalists for diaspora
communities for Cosmopolitan's favoring
human rights and international justice
institutions as well as religious
communities within and across national
borders identity politics seems were
also prominent in separatist regional
movements like those in Cameroon
Catalonia Chechnya Corsica Kurdistan
nagorno-karabakh in Azerbaijan Scotland
Quebec Transnistria and Moldova in many
other places we should also not forget
the new transnational corporations some
with gross revenues that exceed those of
most states constantly strive to foster
strong senses of identity and allegiance
and their employees chiefly but by no
means exclusively through economic
stories the conceptions they foster can
mean that they're beep they're people
pay more as corporate loyalists than as
national citizens googles cosmopolitan
identity for example is clear on its
website which states our mission is to
organize the world's information and
make it universally accessible and
useful because the company is dedicated
to creating opportunity for everyone so
the website heralds Google's endeavours
in many lands most of these social
movements advocacy groups cultural
associations religious communities
regional autonomy or separatism
proponents and multinational
corporations convey at least at times
the message that members should give
their loyalties first and foremost to
them rather than to the frequently
ineffective governments of the states
they inhabit they also deliver those
messages far more rapidly more widely
more frequently and through more media
than ever before
so they to contribute mightily to the
cacophony of clashing stories of people
hood that is I suggest increasingly the
soundtrack
of everyday life for most people around
the world in the 21st century nor is
there any longer any overarching global
story of friends and enemies that
provides order structure and stability
to our multiple political identities in
the way the Cold War once did the
ubiquity of concerns about terrorism
throughout the world does not fill this
gap the great difference is that much of
the world openly embraced communism once
while much of the rest of the world
celebrated capitalism creating a
relatively clear constant structure of
identities and alliances on both sides
but today virtually all states and
people's professed to oppose terrorism
they simply dispute vigorously and
ceaselessly over which groups really are
terrorists and which are instead valiant
Freedom Fighters or Noble servants of a
holy cause even national States
designation of groups they oppose as
terrorists or champion as heroes can
shift rapidly witness Ronald Reagan's
fervent praise made in the 1980s for the
Afghani Mujahideen who served soon
turned into the less beloved Taliban as
well as the early employment in aid the
CIA provided to sodom Hussein later
compared by former CIA director George
HW Bush to Hitler all this means that
few people can bring order to the
clashing claims of political identities
in the contemporary world by simply
deciding whether they are in the end for
or against terrorism as they once could
by deciding whether they were for
communism or the self-proclaimed free
world people instead are engulfed by
information about innumerable different
kinds of political communities and
associations many of which advance
claims on their allegiance many of which
do so in terms of appeals to identities
that people feel they do possess in
value at least to some degree so many
people feel pulled and torn in different
directions as this clamorous chorus of
political stories has accompanied the
extensive economic and cultural
transformations of recent years
transformations that often present real
as well as imagined threats to people's
economic livelihood social statuses and
valued ways of life efforts to find
footing on shifting ground have given
rise to
nationalist forms of populism remains
true that the most dominant most
familiar stories of political people
hood in the lives of all those who
inhabit the world today are stories of
nation-states they are stories that
still resonate deeply with billions of
people even if their states appear all
to ineffective sometimes embattled
sometimes corrupt their stories that can
readily be told with the simplicity
clarity and authority the proponents of
rival senses of political identity often
can only achieve with great difficulty
it's also very easy to tell stories of
the plight of many modern nation-states
in ways that assign blame for all of
today's problems on the forces of
economic globalization on racial ethnic
and religious minorities and immigrants
on everything and everyone that appears
to be making the nation less than it is
thought to once have been and less than
its members would like it to be and some
when we consider not only the ways that
economic and cultural changes are
constructing the landscape of
contemporary politics but also the ways
that clashing stories of people hood are
multiplying and how they are at the same
time dividing us we can better grasp the
challenges we face we can recognize why
more pathological forms of populism more
narrowly nationalistic racial and
religious more exclusionary and
repressive stories of who the people are
and why they deserve to rule are proving
to have such broad and deep appeal in
many parts of the world today based on
that recognition we can begin to form
some ideas of how we can best respond to
the concerns and aspirations that
provide much of the power of these
pathological populism
or at least that's what I'll try to show
in the next two lectures
[Applause]
identity politics will prioritize that
cultural aspect over the economic aspect
and if both of those things are
necessary for populism to arise then how
does identity politics play
well populist stories often feature a
cultural identity that people present as
embattled in one way or another they
often have anti-immigrant themes because
they say the immigrants are transforming
our traditional cultural identity and
they say they impose economic burdens
and produce political problems as well
so here I agree with John Brunner
Moeller populism
is a form of identity politics and
that's why I think you need to pay
attention to the story of who the people
are yeah I mean it's either the
definition of elites versus people seems
like an extremely it's maybe too minimal
in the sense that every political leader
who's fighting against an established
order will seek to mobilize the people
right that's one question I and so who
was not a populist and second question
is why is nationalism such a powerful
thing meaning if there are so many other
identities you could presumably mobilize
people on why is it that this one
identity is the one that people seem
willing to fight and die for about both
excellent questions in regard to the
first one reason that I don't like a
very narrow definition of populism is
that it can easily verge into a kind of
denunciation of democracy because you're
absolutely right that every Democratic
leader claims to champion the people now
they don't always do it through a
rhetoric of focusing on specific elites
as the source of all evil in the way
that the minimal definition of populist
holds FDR did he attacked plutocrats and
that is a classic populist kind of
appeal but the during the cold war era
where there were calls for national
unity against foreign enemies that's a
kind of national appeal it isn't
populist in this people versus elites
theme so that's distinguishable
Eisenhower didn't run on a populist
platform he ran on I like Ike which is
popular appeal but not he wasn't
attacking and evil elite in the same way
although you're always criticizing your
opponents to some extent so there all
the rhetoric converge into that but so I
think most Democratic leaders have
rhetoric that is at least part of the
time populist rhetoric that's why I'm
worried that if worried that if we
define populism is inherently bad we are
in danger of a defining democracy as
inherently
and I'm not ready to do that
why does nationalism have the appeal
that it does I think that that political
identity like all political identities I
think like all human identities is
significantly shaped by social and
political institutions and forces over
time but in ways that become deeply
entrenched so that second nature can
become close to first nature for many
people and the late 20th century world
was a product of a long historical
development in which governments began
to recognize each other as sovereign
nation-states in this Treaty of
Westphalia kind of understanding of the
way the world should be structured as
national states that gained their
authority partly because they give
recognition other national states other
national states give it to them and then
domestically they create institutions of
Education religion socialization in many
forms that foster a sense of national
identity that and they've been doing it
now for a long time in many parts of the
world so that if you grew up saying the
pledge of allegiance to the flag as I
did you have fostered a sense of innate
identity as an American citizen and even
in more recent ones there's an awareness
that the world is structured is this
competition of nation-states and so it
makes sense to be loyal to your team and
the social psychologists have shown over
and over again that as soon as you tell
people you're in this group and not that
group they seize on it that's true for
all identities but national identities
are ones where governments are telling
them this is your team over and over and
over again it's a feature I part of my
stories people would claim it's a
feature of all political rhetoric that
it says you are part of this people and
you should be because this is what's
good for you and people hear these
stories primarily as national stories
more than
the others so that's why it's most
powerful but I don't think it'll
necessarily always be that way it hasn't
always been that way and may not be that
way forever those national stories are
contested now but my point is that
people are pushing back and precisely
because so many people have been
socialized in them and it also just
seems realistic that you have to value
your national state identity to compete
in the world they have particular power
another Rogers in the lecture writers
were babies
was more expensive leader less
minimalistic and I just wanted to bring
up two of the elements in the definition
and because I'm wondering you know if
what we gained by having those is
greater than by not having those in
being able to explain really populism
you mentioned that there's something
that they know the lecture so I want to
see what you think about the two of his
claim there's one is that populism is
usually associated with I think what
they call communicative low style from
this many others and you know and then
another one is that here I give that
protection of that populism is my
ideology that means or seeks protection
from above and from below from above
meaning from this release also mention
from below meaning immigrants all right
so these honors that I thought of it
then the finish line is view of others
may also they also help me understand
phenomena potterson that seems very
vague right and
so I wonder if what we gain analytically
by having a few of these elements that
project maker added it's not worthy
compared to a more minimalist definition
like the one you or I presented well
it's worth thinking about and I will
think about it
I am I think it's true that most
populist leaders speak in a kind of
popular vernacular whether they have a
low communicative style is that the way
you put it yeah I'm not sure that that's
universally true I don't think it's it's
necessary I do think it's an asset you
know but I you know I do think FDR was
populist in a lot of his rhetoric and it
wasn't in a low communicative style and
the the description of the immigrants as
a threat from below I would prefer to
subscribe that as a threat from outside
the low assumes maybe populist see it
that way or some populist see it that
way but although I do think that there
is a tendency of populist movements to
be nativist to be anti-immigrant even
that is a matter of degree the American
people's party certainly did have a lot
of native leaders who were suspicious of
foreign labor but at times they forged
alliances with labor movements that
consisted primarily of immigrant labor
and you think of Bernie Sanders today I
think Bernie deserves to be called a
populist I don't think his rhetoric is
low and I also don't think he's
anti-immigrant well I got to let other
people in I'm gonna go over this side of
the room now
you talk a bit about your second
attendance we live in a post-colonial
post-cold-war and I wanted to ask you
whether this is this is really kind of
development story because like I work on
Lima and the problem of clashing swords
and historical situation is very
different but I think in many ways there
are a lot of similarities when it comes
to narratives so would you say a little
bit more about why you think that
specific our specific historical
situation is well I'd be likely to
repeat what I just said which is that
you got with the end of empires a
multiplication of new nations struggling
for census of identity and with the end
of the Cold War again a multiplication
of new nations and also less of the
pressures of a world order that chose
you to that compelled you to choose
sides I think those are distinct from
the situation of Germany in the 20s and
30s but I don't think that those
circumstances are the only ones under
which nationalist populist movements can
arise I think that Germany clearly was
experiencing some specific circumstances
of national humiliation and economic
disaster that created conditions that
led to the appeal of the Nazis and a
strongman leader and all that and that
can happen in circumstances other than
the ones we have today but so I'm not
saying these are the only circumstances
in which nationalist populism z' arise
and there is some common denominator in
periods have changed in turmoil and
sense of law status and humiliation I
just think you know we weren't getting
we did get some fascist movements in a
variety of countries are not denying
that in the 1930s with the depression
leak contributing to the discrediting of
capitalism I just think that in the
current moment it's these most recent
developments that help us understand
what's happening now where do you find
the inspiration and the support
primarily in the ethnographic accounts
that's trying to look at what's happened
through contextual analyses of different
situations and adding them up so I don't
do social psychology experiments to
explain it I collect stories strident
stories you said that modern technology
makes those cultural problems or
December they're being kind of
realistically exacerbated so is there
just a stronger factor for those
communities being kind of these
narratives or is there an increasing
imbalance of political power that is
also contributing
it's a question to which I don't have a
confident answer except to say I'm
pretty sure both things are going on and
which has the relative greater weight is
a subject for empirical investigation
that I'd certainly like to see in some
circumstances it may be one in some
circumstances it may be another that is
to say some groups may be seriously
disempowered other groups not so
disempowered but they're getting a lot
of messages that still upset them and so
I can't give up a confident answer but I
think it's a question worth exploring
interesting I was I started with
Neanderthals whether I should think of
18th century early 19th century United
States federal society were federal
Mexico at that time as sort of fitting
with this framework of competing stories
of people hood and was there a cacophony
at that time or was it just like there's
two stories when a state identity versus
a national identity or is that something
that you think is different from the
framework that you've proposed today I
think that there is an inter weaving of
state and nation building that doesn't
always go the same way in all times in
places that sometimes there is a
construction of native a sense of
national identity that then seeks a
state more often I think there's an
effort to construct a state that then
tries to foster a sense of national
identity and there's a lot of excellent
literature on how States tried to foster
senses of national identity you know
from from peasants into Frenchmen
Britons by Linda Colley who used to be
here and the there are a number of works
that show how with the rise of the
nation-state states were trying to
foster a sense of national identity and
that was often context
there was certainly cacophony there's
certainly resistance not all that
resistance has gone away and much of it
is being revived by separatist movements
now nation and state building always
incomplete but we're under circumstances
you know in some circumstances favored
that those nation building enterprises
now are under circumstances that work
against those state led nation building
enterprises but again the circumstances
the challenge those are also unsettling
to people in ways that give nationalist
leaders opportunities to pushback by
saying we need state policies that
foster a sense of common identity and
we'll see tomorrow that a lot of
people's response to issues of
immigration are reluctantly to say what
we really do need to assimilate them
into a sense of national identity more
effectively than we're doing I don't
know if that's an adequate answer or not
but this idea the cacophony of stories I
really like to figure because it speaks
to for example this idea fake-nice right
you know this displacement of truth and
trying to grasp or something and funny
and
Rhaegar's headline my 66 year old just
shared right
I wouldn't new is that some does that
tie to it in this in the fact that big
news are sort of symptomatic of this
narrative being posed does that mean
that maybe just saying all they're not
tracing not enough then maybe the way to
do it is to say you know it's not just
enough to provide a graph saying well
this is false but rather a teacher
narrated so that's sort of one topic in
the second one is you brought up a nest
of a class definition of populism which
is interesting is he doesn't define
populism as an ideology as much as a
sort of an ethos in the language of
rhetoric right because in that every
single I definitely keep pointed up can
have those sort of anti liberal
anti-democratic stand so to what extent
do you agree with him with your sort of
thin definition so on the first point I
do think that technology is contributing
to a situation of enabling fragmentation
and polarization through creation of
echo chambers and so forth as many have
argued I think that's true I don't like
using technology as the driving causal
explanation because I think technology
is always what we do with it but we
can't entirely control what we do with
it I accept that but rather than blaming
technology I do go in the direction of
counter narratives just as you are
suggesting and fundamentally I think I'm
in agreement with low cloud that you can
have a populist way of structuring and
presenting and seeing politics tied to a
whole wide range of particular policies
the does that mean it's not an ideology
well I would say as the kind of common
denominator you might say it's not an
ideology but again every particular
populist movement does have its own
story of the people of their grievances
of their aspirations and Worth and so in
that sense populism
maybe a characteristic that is true of a
family of ideologies and not an ideology
itself but you want to understand any
particular populist movement unless you
look at their ideology and what's
happening in the world is their
surroundings
yeah I think those are definitely right
a lot of those goes into arguments about
the economic causes of our current
condition and I didn't go through all
those but again it's not because I
challenged them it's because a lot of
other people are going through them and
I do think that in the post-cold war
world we had the rise of the kind of
economic institutions and policies
exercising power that people call
neoliberal and that they helped some
people and didn't help or actively hurt
a whole lot of others and that that
helped create the conditions for
populist movements I don't think it's
the whole story but I also think it
definitely is part of the story
including some quite legitimate
grievances that Trump spoke to in that
populist leaders in other countries
spoken to yeah I would like to have a
two-hour conversation with viewers
you're lucky that your time is almost up
today will you be here for a few days
I'm here all week try the veal yeah I'm
Matt would please like this is the first
of three lectures here the next couple
days I mean I'm in town from the
moderator to be able to ask I hope you
get on the stage and that you compose a
Hamilton rendition of your talk it would
be so educational and put it to music
into an opera and it'll be so
educational to everybody who comes to
New York City to hear you wouldn't you
love to do that because very few people
understand what you do let alone how
were able to articulate it and to
enunciate it too thank you Wow well
thank you but as far as a musical is
concerned as Clint Eastwood once
remarked a man's got to know his
limitations now if you gain interest
lin-manuel Miranda I'm all for it
so I appreciate the fact that you don't
want to turn fades untested which you
call anti elitism I would say populism
also has a distinctive anti
institutionalism and it's that threat to
the rule of law that I think is what's
disturbing sort of missed in this entire
Buddhism it's the it's the sense that we
as the people group identity
institutions institutions I understand
the concern and I I think it's certainly
true that there are populist movements
in the world today that use
constitutional forms but really simply
to impose their will in a way that
defies rule of law as I referred to
briefly I also understand that there is
at least the potential in populist
ideology the people are the source of
all legitimacy you can use that to
overrun all sorts of procedural barriers
processes and structures and so it can
be anti institutional in that sense I'm
not persuaded that that is inherent in
populism you know I do refer back to the
American people's party which was a
relatively short-lived an imperfect
political phenomenon and it got worse
over time and I'm conscious of all that
but at the same time
although they had some proposals that
seemed radical at the time and later
came to be adopted and some that
genuinely were pretty radical they
really saw themselves as true to the
Constitution and were open engaged in
debates about constitutional limits of
powers and structures that I think they
took seriously I see the danger that
populism can disregard institutions in
the name of the people's will it's a
real danger whether we should make that
a definition part of the definition of
populism I'm reluctant to accept maybe
eventually I'll have to accept it
here she hasn't asked about your I find
this really bleak tomorrow but do you
have a sense okay is there any hope that
in terms of our identities in the world
and identifying ourselves in opposition
to others that intersectionality
intersectionality
okay is there any hope does any help
light there in terms of people seeing
themselves and there are people who ever
their people are as having a whole web
of identities is that hopeful or is that
gonna mean just a more fragmentation I
mean is there any hope that other than I
almost hear you saying maybe I miss
hearing it during the Cold War at least
we had something to identify ourselves
something clear that people can identify
themselves against and now there's so
many competing identities are you
hopeful or are you pessimistic about you
know we've gone from Neanderthals to
yeah
so the web of identities phrase is close
to one that I will use tomorrow so and
what I'd say is I think that there is a
solid basis for hope but no guarantees
and so you know it's up to us to take
things in a better rather than worse
direction and I do think it's possible
but I don't think it's by any means
inevitable we're in very tough times now
and it wouldn't be intellectually honest
to pretend otherwise but I don't think
it's hopeless and I do think it requires
something that's very demanding and this
is what we'll be talking about that
we're not going to get such an easy
story of us versus them as we had in the
Cold War we have to get people used to
accepting some more complicated stories
in which they have multiple identities
and allegiances and but they also share
things with multiple different groups
and the challenge of telling these more
complicated stories in ways that people
don't find unduly confusing unsettling
or threatening that's the challenge but
I do think it it can be done you know
and I'll throw out an example now that I
don't want to pursue in great depth
because it's a very troubled one right
now but I was at a conference in Europe
where they were debating the fate of the
European Union and saying there's no
common sense of European identity and
strong enough to compel Allegiance and
we're seeing lots of evidence that
that's true at the same time a lot of
people argued that the young people in
Europe had grown up in a world in which
they could routinely across what used to
be national borders that were hard to
cross and many of them found it
inconceivable that they would give this
up and that means that they thought of
their identity as both national and
European in at least some important
respects and we're comfortable with that
and I think that there are ways of
trying to
build support for these more complicated
multiple senses of identity after all we
all already do have complicated and
multiple senses of identity and we just
need a politics that helps but you had a
hand up we'll let you get the last word
either kind of identity can work and I'd
say for different people at different
times it was more one than another but
it is unfortunately true that often the
most politically effective one is one
that demonizes your opposition rather
than offers a positive vision of
yourself but I like to note that even
demonization of opposition of opponents
can be overcome in some circumstances
Buffy the Vampire Slayer
reached peace with some that had been
demonized because they actually were
demons but nonetheless they managed to
find some common ground
[Applause]
[Music]